paul gérard 18 ans est l'un des
meilleurs apnéistes français de sa
génération hauteur de 167 m aux derniers
championnats de france le jeune prodige
a réussi à se faire un nom dans le monde
de l'apnée dynamique une discipline qui
l'a découvert en 2012
en fait c'est ma mère et mon grand-père
il pratiqua depuis tout petit
et en fait ma mère à l'âge de 12 ans
elle m'a dit pourquoi ça te dirait
d'aller plonger une fois ou deux et puis
on est parti pour osh et puis ça m'a
directement plus et demi
donc à partir de là à l'apnée
aujourd'hui paul est addict à ce sport à
la piste s'entraînent une à trois fois
par semaine pendant deux heures entre
saint germain les saint cyr l'école des
sessions qui lui permettent également de
travailler son mental sous l'eau au
début je pense à ma glisse donc je pense
à l'effet clos à sur mon corps et puis
petit à petit au fur et à mesure je
commence à me dire que c'est dur la pnq
que je souffre mais mais j'essaie
justement de passer à autre chose et de
nous concentrer sur ma glisse des
entraînements qui ont payé le jeune
sportif d'un mètre 86 vient d'être
sélectionné pour participer à un stage
avec les espoirs de l'équipe de france
en février prochain à mulhouse
je suis assez impatient d'y être chassé
impatient de rencontrer tout le monde de
partager d'un d'échangé pour une
expérience qui lui permettra peut-être
de réaliser l'un de ses plus grands
objectifs aller au delà des 200 m en
apnée d'ici les deux prochaines années